c'est l'une des batailles les plus
meurtrières de la guerre en Ukraine
abarthout armée russe et ukrainienne se
disputent chaque mètre carré depuis
plusieurs mois né pour les États-Unis
Moscou paye un très lourd tribu selon
les services de renseignement américain
20 000 soldats russes ont été tués et
80000 blessés sur le sol ukrainien
depuis décembre dernier parmi les 20 000
personnes tuées près de la moitié était
de soldats de Wagner et la majorité
était d'anciens prisonniers russes jetés
dans les combats à barkout sans
entraînement ni commandement militaire
suffisant
Wagner ce groupe paramilitaire russe
impliqué dans la guerre en Ukraine et
dont le chef efghani Prigogine est
présent autour de barmut si la Russie a
toujours refusé de rendre public le
bilan des combats trigogine se fend
régulièrement de déclaration qui
témoignent de l'intensité des combats
dernier exemple en date ce lundi dans
une vidéo où il demande désarmement
supplémentaires à Moscou
[Musique]
on a 300 tonnes de munitions
d'artillerie par jour ça représente 10
containers ce qui est très peu
on ne nous donne qu'un tiers de ce dont
nous avons besoin d'un boulet
alors que la Russie revendique le
contrôle de 80 % de darkmouth les
américains affirment que le Kremlin a
conquis qu'une petite partie de la ville
pour les Russes la prise de darkmouth
représenterait la première victoire
d'ampleur après des mois de revers sur
le front ukrainien